Almost no one has the time to
investigate headlines like this one seen
by tens of millions of people that AI
models don't actually reason at all.
They just memorize patterns. AGI is
mostly hype and even the underlying
Apple paper quoted says it's an illusion
of thinking. This was picked up in
mainstream outlets like the Guardian
which quoted it as being a pretty
devastating Apple paper. So, what are
people supposed to believe when half the
headlines are about an imminent AI job
apocalypse and the other half are about
LLMs all being fake? Well, hopefully
you'll find that I'm not trying to sell
a narrative. I'll just say what I found
having read the 30page paper in full and
the surrounding analyses. I'll also end
with a recommendation on which model you
should use and yes, touch on the brand
new 03 Pro from OpenAI. Although I would
say that the $200 price per month to
access that model is not for the
unwashed masses like you guys. Some very
quick context on why a post like this
one gets tens of millions of views and
coverage in the mainstream media. And
no, it's not just because of the
unnecessarily frantic breaking at the
start. It's also because people hear the
claims made by the CEOs of these AI labs
like Sam Orman yesterday posting,
"Humanity is close to building digital
super intelligence. We're past the event
horizon. The takeoff has started. While
the definitions of those terms are
deliberately vague, you can understand
people paying attention. People can see
for themselves how quickly large
language models are improving and they
can read the headlines generated by the
CEO of Anthropic saying there is a white
collar blood bath coming. It's almost
every week now that we get headlines
like this one in the New York Times. So,
it's no wonder people are paying
attention. Now, some would say cynically
that Apple seemed to be producing more
papers quote debunking AI than actually
improving AI. But let's set that
cynicism aside. The paper essentially
claimed that large language models don't
follow explicit algorithms and struggle
with puzzles when there are sufficient
degrees of complexity. Puzzles like the
Tower of Hanoi challenge where you've
got to move a tower of discs from one
place to another, but never place a
larger disc on top a smaller one. They
also tested the models on games like
checkers where you've got to move the
blue tokens all the way to the right and
the red tokens to the left following the
rules of checkers. And games like river
crossing which might be more familiar to
you as the fox and chicken challenge
where you've got to go to the other side
of the river without leaving the fox
with the chicken. All of these games of
course can be and were scaled up in
complexity the more pieces you
introduce. If models were a
pre-programmed set of algorithms, like a
calculator, then it shouldn't matter how
many discs or checkers or blocks you
have. Performance should be 100% all the
time. Shocker, the paper showed that
they're not that, and performance
dropped off noticeably the more complex
the task got. But this has been known
for years now about large language
models. They're not traditional software
where the same input always leads to the
same output. Nor of course are they
fully randomized either, otherwise they
couldn't pass a single benchmark. They
are probabilistic neural networks
somewhere in between the two extremes.
And the perfect example comes with
multiplication. Again, I could have
added breaking to the title of this
video, but this has been known about for
several years now. If you don't give
models access to any tools and ask them
to perform a multiplication, then the
moment the digits of the multiplication
get too large, they start to fail
dramatically. Not occasionally getting
it right, just never getting the sum
right. If the number of digits is small
enough, the models can reason their way
to the correct answer. And as you can
see in the difference between 01 mini
from OpenAI and 03 mini, performance is
incrementally improving. In other words,
it takes a bigger number of digits to
flamx the latest models. But again, it
must be emphasized that even with the
very latest, the very best models you
can access, if you don't give them
tools, they will eventually reach a
point where they just simply can't
multiply two numbers. But this will
always be the case because these models
aren't designed to be fully predictable.
They're designed to be generative.
They're not designed to be software.
They're designed to use software. They
want to produce plausible outputs, which
is why they'll hallucinate when you ask
them questions they can't handle. Here,
for example, I gave a calculation to
Claude for Opus, the latest model from
Anthropic, and Gemini 2.5 Pro, the
latest model from Google DeepMind. But I
didn't give them access to tools. They
were never going to get this right. But
rather than say I don't know, they just
hallucinated the answer in both cases.
The funny thing was these answers were
plausible in that they ended in twos and
began with 67, which the correct answer
does. These models are after all very
convincing BS's. But what the paper
ignored is that these models can use
tools and use them very effectively.
Here's that same clawed for opus, but
this time allowed to use code. It got
the answer right. And notice I didn't
even say use code or use a tool. it knew
to do so. So for me what was surprising
is that this Apple paper found it
surprising that large reasoning models
they call them can't perform exact
computation. We know they can't. Now
several other people before me have
pointed out another fatal weakness with
the paper which is they describe
accuracy ultimately collapsing towards
zero beyond a certain level of
complexity because models are
constrained with how many tokens or
parts of a word if you like that they
can output in one go. In the case of the
Clawude model from Anthropic that was
tested, that token limit is 128,000
tokens. But some of the questions tested
required more than that number of
tokens. So even if the models were
trained to be calculators, which they're
not, they weren't given enough space to
output the requisite number of tokens.
For me, then it's to the credit of the
models that they recognized their own
output limits and then outputed what the
paper calls shorter traces. basically
giving up because they quote knew they
wouldn't have the space to output the
required answer. Instead, the models
would output things like here is the
algorithm you need to use or the tool
you need to use, which I think is
reasonable. One quick detail that I
think many people missed is the paper
actually admits that it originally
wanted to compare thinking versus
non-thinking models. You know, those
ones output long chains of thought
versus those that don't on math
benchmarks. Because the results didn't
quite conform to the narrative they were
expecting and thinking models did indeed
outperform non-thinking models with the
same compute budget, they actually
abandoned math benchmark and then
resorted to the puzzles. I guess what
I'm saying is I slightly feel like the
authors came to testing the thinking
models with a preconceived notion about
their lack of ability. Another learning
moment for us all from the paper comes
from their surprise, the Apple authors,
that when they provide the algorithm in
the prompt, the algorithm to solve these
puzzles, the models still often fail.
They're surprised by this and deem it
noteworthy because they say, "Surely
finding the solution requires more
computation than merely executing a
given algorithm." But you guys have
tweaked this all by now. These are not
calculators. They're not designed for
executing algorithms because they are
instead neural networks that are
probabilistic. Even if there is a 99.9%
chance that they output the correct next
step, when there's millions of steps
involved, they will eventually make a
mistake. Remember multiplication where
of course the language models know the
quote algorithm to perform a multiply
step. Indeed, the models are derived
through matrix multiplication, but that
does not mean that given enough steps
required, they won't start making
mistakes. The conclusion of the paper
then teed things up for the headline
writers because they say we may be
encountering fundamental barriers to
generalizable reasoning. Now do forgive
me for pointing this out but that quote
limitation to generalized reasoning has
been pointed out by experts like
Professor Ralph who I interviewed back
in December of 2023 on my Patreon. This
is not a quote breaking news type of
situation. You may also find it
interesting that one researcher used
Claude for Opus and named that model as
a co-author in a paper pointing out all
the flaws of the Apple paper. Flaws even
I missed like certain of the questions
being impossible to answer due to
logical impossibility. So no, to quote
an article featured in the Guardian from
Gary Marcus, the tech world is not
reeling from a paper that shows the
powers of the new generation of AI have
been wildly oversold. I would go as far
as to say that there isn't a single
serious AI researcher that would have
been surprised by the results of that
paper. That is not, of course, to say
that these models don't make basic
reasoning mistakes in simple scenarios
or at least semi-simple scenarios. I'm
the author of a benchmark called
SimpleBench designed to test models on
such scenarios. For example, I tested
the brand new 03 Pro on this scenario in
which models tend not to spot that the
glove would just fall onto the road.
This is despite, by the way, thinking
for 18 minutes. If you want to learn
more about Symbol Bench, by the way, the
link is in the description. And I'll end
this video with my recommendation of
which model you should check out if
you're just used to, say, for example,
the free chatbt. The 03 Pro API from
OpenAI failed, by the way, which is why
we don't have a result yet for that
model. Of course, the failure modes go
far beyond the simple scenarios featured
in SimpleBench. Here's one quirk many of
you may not know about. This is the
brand new VO3 from Google Gemini, and I
said, output a London scene with
absolutely zero lampost. Not a single
lampost in sight.
Of course, if you lean in to the
hallucinations of generative models, you
can get creative outputs like this one
from V3. dog in them. Will egg prices go
up this month? I think we'll hit $20.
Now, obviously, this is a quirky advert,
but think of the immense amount of money
that the company quote saved by not
using actors, sets, or props for this
advert. That's why I don't want you guys
to be as shocked as this Sky News
presenter in Britain, and this has got
hundreds of thousands of views, where he
noticed Chacht hallucinating an answer,
in this case, a transcript. This
generated several news segments as well
as this article saying, "Can we trust
chatbt despite it hallucinating
answers?" This all then comes back to us
being able to hold two thoughts in our
head at the same time, which is that
LLMs are swiftly catching up on human
performance across almost all textbased
domains, but they have almost no
hesitation in generating mistruths, you
could say, like many humans. So if human
performance is your yard stick, they are
catching up fast and can BS like the
best of us. But language models like
chatbt, Gemini, and Claude are not
supercomputers. They're not the kind of
AI that can, for example, predict the
weather. Their real breakthroughs, as
with human breakthroughs, come when they
use tools in an environment that
corrects their BS for them. That can
lead to genuine scientific advance. And
if you want to learn more about that,
check out my Alpha Evolve video.
Frankly, having made that video, I was
quite surprised to hear Samman say,
"It's going to be 2026 when we see the
arrival of systems that can figure out
novel insights." As far as I'm
concerned, we have that now. Again, not
LLMs on their own, but LLMs in
combination with symbolic systems. So,
while language models can't yet solo
super intelligence, which one should you
use? Well, let me give you one
cautionary word on benchmarks and a
little bit of advice. In just the last
48 hours, we got 03 Pro from OpenAI at
the $200 tier. I'm sure though that will
eventually filter down to the $20 here.
And of course, the benchmark results
were pretty impressive on competition
level mathematics, 93% on really hard
PhD level science questions, 84% and
competitive coding. You can see the ELO
ranking here. My cautionary note though
comes from the results you can see below
for the 03 model, not 03 Pro, but the 03
model that OpenAI showcased on day 12 of
Christmas in December 2024. As you can
see, today's 03 Pro mostly underperforms
that system teased back in December. So,
that's the cautionary note that you
often have to look beyond the headline
benchmark results to see how these
models perform on your use case. The
word of advice is that when you're
looking at benchmarks, companies will
often either not compare to other model
providers at all, as in the case of
OpenAI these days, or like Anthropic
with their Claude series of models. They
will show you multiple benchmarks, but
not be terribly clear about the multiple
parallel attempts they took to get their
record high scores or about the serious
usage limitations they have for their
bigger model or the massively elevated
price for that model. Which brings me to
my current recommendation. If you just
want to use a model for free, albeit
with caps, of course, and that would be
Google's Gemini 2.5 Pro. Yes, I am
slightly influenced by its top score on
SimpleBench and the fact you get a few
uses of the VO video generator model. An
honorary mention goes to Deepseek R1,
which is very cheap via the API and at
least comes with a technical report that
we can all read through. Many of you
commented this month that you saw a
pretty noticeable boost in production
quality for my Deepseek documentary. And
there's more to come where that came
from. But that boost was in no small
part to my video editor choosing Story
Blocks, the sponsors of today's video.
We picked them actually before any
sponsorship, partly due to the unlimited
downloads of varied highquality media at
their set subscription cost, but partly
due to the clear-cut licensing wherein
anything we downloaded with Storyblocks
was 100% royalty-free. If you want to
get started with unlimited stock media
downloads, head to
storyblocks.com/iexplained,
link in the description. I hope that
helped give you some signal amongst the
noise.